baby wedding maybe two please letting
baby
my age you probably rethought how your
life could be never backpack gear up or
join the Peace Corps we're giving up
everything to go be one with nature so
then I remember that peeing in the
forest is gross and I should just stay
on course
but I can't even decide which cheap-ass
carpet freshener I should buy or if I
even like the guy inland what'd you call
me
no nothing isn't wrong that I would
rather finish the scarf than go out with
my friends tonight remember when life
was simple and your biggest decision of
the prom dress find myself getting
overly nostalgic for a high school high
school sucked
even though I know I want a kid someday
the thought of it kind of terrifies me
and it kills me because both my parents
and sister had a house and a baby at the
age of 25 stress and worry of budgets
bills and taxes can take it out in your
life I'm not sure why but I feel
incredibly depressed when watching happy
couples do their finances together which
is probably why I still send my taxes to
my dad finally we wish you could just
choose something and stick to it
and then you're right back to where you
started and the moment you realize that
your 20s aren't turning out as you
expected research panic
[Music]
but you realize the panicking gets you
nowhere a life's not a race comparing
your path to the path of other people
nonsense it's better to take a deep
breath
and change your expectations and have
the confidence to reinvent yourself
just going here
[Music]